[Musique]
bon les enfants nié depuis le temps
qu'on attendait d'être là donc là je
présente daniel
donc c'est le guide et limited il
connaît le dimitile comme sa poche donc
on l'écouté on fait pas forcément comme
d'habitude d'accord bienvenu ici sur le
site du capitaine dimitile alors
dimitile ça tient son nom d'un célèbre
esclaves malgaches qui était surnommé
l'insaisissable parce que justement il
échappe et toujours aux chasseurs de
marrons donc voilà j'espère que ça va
vous intéresser que ça va bien se passer
noir c'est intéressant parce qu'on dit
bon alors les jeunes ce que je vais vous
demander c'est de bien rester grouper
ses mesures de sécurité importantes il
ya des sentiers là qui sont fermées par
un côté préfectoral qu'en fait il ya des
glissements de terrain des éboulis et
des personnes qui sont portées disparues
et qui ont perdu la vie donc moi j'ai
pas envie que ça arrive aujourd'hui on
est là avec votre professeur il est
responsable de vos kitty il faut que ça
se passe bien ok c'est parti alors on y
va
[Musique]
il
t'es qui toi sur c'est quoi tous ces
bruits de gens sont calmes au calme mais
appelle ma jian nous les bonnes sorties
marron et na loba chasseurs pour dany
c'est plus un look ou des chasseurs
senti marron mais de quoi tu me parles
j'étais avec ma classe mois bonnes
chaussures chercher avec l'usi avec le
bonne chère pour dan ou banner tout
coupe notre main coupe notre oreille et
a les mots que le bonhomme est blanc
dans les bas et que sa classe pour se
raconte de toute façon et tout à moi ne
traîne pas allons-nous bana pourquoi
fini rhodanien non non non je te connais
pas je ne suis pas mécontent a donné
quoi il reste la main moi mais ça va
ok attend
mais voudrait montrant l'ex plantes
[Musique]
un papillon comme un l'émotion si ces
vols
il voudrait mon corps y explore
il
un papillon intimidations 6
mon talon
[Musique]
à
mon corps candidat n'est qu'un tel
on est où là
cela nous les côtés les bonnes quand
marron mais comme l'anus à tomber il
fait noir vaut mieux notés à la pouvoir
prendre de risques comment t'est arrivé
ici - mettez un esclave avec ma famille
et comme le bonnet blanc teta pas nous
ma décideurs marron et puis depuis ce
jour là mais vivent dans les montagnes
mais va les fatiguer la mal est fait le
guet pour voir si le bon chasseur et
repose à aubiac
[Musique]
ma terral
alors préparez à l'étalon la guette déjà
monde présente à moi j'appelle noah mais
travail de bonnes s'entiche la réunion
et la joie du mas décida ménez est ici
le dimitile
ou la finma giné
bonne histoire laisse passer d'un
sentier notre passé hasard alors alors
au monde courant le temps alors si la
ligne le temps l'esclavagé pèse l'a pris
longtemps pour comprendre le malaise
tout ça est ce qu a obligé à les marrons
push ap la loi bonne coulon tout cet
enfant tout ça tu m'as tu diras n'est
fait partie notre patrimoine commun
payan qu'est the tv juste volé ce matin
paix pilote liberté
[Musique]